[Music]
the crisis on the border is a
manufactured crisis and we are not
interested in participating in this
political theater Democrats like Gavin
Newsome slamming Trump for deploying
troops to the border even calling it an
absolute stunt but what about what he's
getting done for veterans even in New
York Times op-ed had to admit quote
Donald Trump is getting it right on
veterans care earlier this week Laura
and I spoke to someone who knows a thing
or two about caring for the veterans
community launch
I just want to join everybody a
[Applause]
remarkable video and it went on and on
for actor Gary Sinise to thank him for
the work he's done to help our nation's
veterans the videos released coincides
with the publication of Gary's new
memoir grateful American which
chronicles his life acting career and
work with the Gary Sinise foundation
joining us now is Gary Sinise thank you
for being here Gary thank you it's good
it's great to see you it's been oh it's
been a while my friend yeah Wow what was
your reaction when you when you saw that
video we cut it down just there all time
of the second went on and on no I wasn't
I was stunned I they completely and
totally surprised me with it I'm on this
book to her now I'm going around the
country and doing interviews and that
kind of thing and promoting so my head
has just got to get here got to get
there and they made me sit down and I
said what's going on and they turned
that on and I was just I was overwhelmed
and shocked we're gonna get to the end
there's a moment in the end of your book
which I want to touch on but for people
who aren't aware of all that you've done
and I can't imagine there are many tell
us again what got you going cuz I heard
over in the makeup room earlier why
aren't there more Gary's out there in
Hollywood why aren't there more Gary's
in the entertainment industry they're
great people they give a lot of money I
understand
but what made you this force in the
military community I I just felt called
to do it at a certain point I have
veterans of my family so you know great
respect there and in my wife's family as
well Vietnam veterans and her family I
have I got involved with Vietnam
veterans back in the in the 80s I
started supporting them I played the
part of Lieutenant Dan and Forrest Gump
and that started me working with our
wounded and then you know after
September 11th I just I was hit with
that and my heart was broken and I saw
us deploying to Iraq and Afghanistan are
people getting hurt and getting killed
and the families struggling and
everything I just raised my hand and
wanted to do something to help my
country and and help those who were
defending her our country and so I just
started and it's just snowballed into
the into a huge mission Gary the the the
Gary Sinise foundation has really
expanded over the last few years started
in 2011 this snowball Express which we
covered at the end of last year it was
an incredible thing I mean Laura saw it
I was there give me a sense of why did
you expand this mission not only to the
veterans but to their families as well
and what are they telling you as a
result of those experiences well before
I started my foundation I was raising my
hand in a lot of different areas I raise
my hand for the USO started entertaining
troops I started supporting various
military charities operating in
different spaces and one of those one of
those charities was this snowball
Express and it was focused on that Gold
Star children and so I started
supporting them and we eventually made a
deal with Disneyworld and take the kids
down there and we folded snowball into
Gary Sinise foundation as a program and
we took the kids to Disney World this
year you have gone through great lengths
to help those who come home and are
impaired and can't take care of
themselves tell us about these Smart
Homes that I've seen you present all
over the country
what are they how'd you get into this
these are for our wounded veterans I
years ago I met the first surviving
quadruple amputees his name's Brendan
Morocco
he was blown up he lost his arms and
legs and we ended up raising money to
build a house for him I did a concert
for him a Staten Island that that's how
I got into the home building projects
now we've done upwards I've been
involved with over 70 these houses my my
foundation just gave me another one away
a couple of weeks ago and you know we
have a lot of very severely wounded
service members they have special needs
we provide these smart technology houses
for them
that offer them a chance to be more
independent within their home because
the home is designed specifically for
them and by doing that it gives their
family more independence because they
don't have to take care of them as much
so we're doing that at the Gary Sinise
foundation constantly I write about that
and grateful American so many of the
great people that I've met and that
we've served these stories aren't shared
and told enough stories like these that
are in this book and I don't know this
could be in some ways required reading
in high school for for young people to
see what it takes to go to war and the
sacrifices that are required of
individuals when they come home still
and I think we don't think about that I
want just real quick I want to ask you
about the last part of your book you
wrote about why you're still doing this
all these years later I mean you go you
gotta ask a lot of people for a lot of
money a lot I mean asking people for
money people like to give money but even
rich people they want to give up their
money right so you're doing that a lot
so why are you still on the mission real
quick because there's people that are in
need out there it's a you know we're
still is still at war we still have
people getting hurt and we still lose
them then we still have gold star
families each each year that you know we
we have to take care of we have a lot of
wounded still and you about the
fragility of life and you've experienced
at your own family your brother-in-law
struggle with cancer your family
struggle with cancer you've gone through
a lot and you are going through a lot
yet you keep giving that's a that's
tough to do it's a mother Teresa thing
give until it hurts I've seen a lot of
need out there but I've also seen the
joy of just showing up and what that can
bring
and I just try to show up and point
people in the right direction to help
these folks and humility is also one of
your great strengths Gary Sinise thank
you so much for being here congrats on
this book it should be required reading
grateful American here on the Ingraham
angle Gary thanks so much thank you
fancy-man grateful